welcome back to Las Vegas now in today's
legal minute we are learning what are
the three biggest reasons people declare
bankruptcy Eric Palacios from Eric
Palacios and Associates the sponsors of
this segment tells us more
hi I'm Eric Palacios welcome to the
legal minute this week's questions is
what are the three biggest reasons
people declare bankruptcy number one
medical bills High medical bills
especially from an unexpected illness or
accident are a leading cause of
bankruptcy number two loss of a job or
reduced income unexpected job loss or
reduction in income can make it
difficult for you to keep up with your
financial obligations this makes it
impossible to stay afloat and number
three simply too much debt little by
little you can take on too much debt
from credit cards personal loans car
payments payday loans or even mortgages
this debt can lead to financial strain
especially if interest rates or required
minimum payments increase if you can't
stay afloat and you're constantly
stressed out about your debt call it
bankruptcy attorney today
of Eric Palacios and Associates a call
on call or their website at
it it's now just ahead and we will be
right